please welcome a true pioneer
[Applause]
yes
hi everybody
oh paul thank you so much for gracing us
with your presents drew please thank you
for having me because
it's never more exciting when a director
is on a show i find well because people
don't know what we do really sometimes
well i do thank you so much um
i wouldn't mind if if if you wouldn't
mind if we could actually take a little
quick look at some of your body of work
will you do me a favor and play my
favorite game behind the scenes with me
i would be honored to ladies and
gentlemen it's behind the scenes
okay
bridesmaids
oh my gosh uh so many great things
happened um you know that the scene
where uh where the the showdown between
um helen and annie uh basically with the
jordan almonds and all that
and the sweaty face
well the way that that was achieved was
kristen wiig just said give me give me a
little can of like evian spray water so
okay so she would do a line and she
would just spray her face and then she'd
do another line she would spray her face
again and do another so she just gets
sweatier and sweatier and sweatier that
was all christian just going like i'm
gonna i'm gonna use this little can of
water all right give it to me for the
heat my favorite movie i mean oh my god
i love this movie i've seen it 25 times
thank um okay so there's a montage in
the middle when they're at the bar kind
of bonding for the first time getting
drunk where they're taping their fingers
together and doing stuff that was them i
was literally we just we're just gonna
like do a bunch of funny stuff i didn't
even kind of know what was gonna be i
said like let's just play around and all
of a sudden melissa goes like can i have
a roll of scotch tape
okay so i go off to do something else i
come back and they've taped their forks
under their hands and suddenly they're
taping their noses up with this thing
and i just okay go and uh and we just
shot for about
a half hour of absolute madness so
and it makes our lives all the better
um
another melissa mccarthy um movie that
we all love spy give me a fly on the
mall moment of spies melissa did a lot
of her her own stunt work on that uh
moped that when we had that big chase
scene i saw that yeah is that true yeah
she did a lot of that riding around for
there's some harder stunts we had
somebody else do but mostly it was it
was her but uh that's how she did it
okay good
melissa mccarthy once again overcomes
all odds and like can do anything
possible okay a simple favor yes i told
you i'm in love with blake lively
and uh you told me a fun fact about her
wardrobe actually in that movie yeah
well we were trying to figure out what
her look was going to be and i wanted to
be very you know like this powerful you
know person and blake just looked over
me and she goes like i want to dress
like you and so because i was normally i
have a three-piece suit i only have a
two-piece on today but i was like well i
would be honored if you would and she
looks spectacular in the movie so okay
finally
freaks and geeks the the character of
sam weir played by john francis daly is
based on me it's basically that's what i
wrote it for but i was a really tall kid
and all my bullies were short and so
when we were trying to cast it i kept
ahead of these like tall kids that we
we'd liked but they weren't quite right
and then we finally came to new york and
met with john francis daley who was
about this tall and he looked like he
was 12.
but he was so good that i ended up
saying okay we'll rewrite it so he's not
a big tall kid he's just this you know a
normal sized kid who gets bullied by
kids his size so
it was supposed to be me but it's much
better as him um now is there a story
that actually like your first project
there's something like you funded it
but it didn't go the way you planned
well i was i was uh i used to be an
actor and uh i was uh on sabrina the
teenage witch in the first season is mr
poole the biology
thank you
that contributes a lot of things mitosis
is there you go if you know the show
that everybody knows that phrase um uh
but so i did the first season and then i
i always wanted to make a movie my own
so i wrote a movie that took that could
be cheap and so i took all my money 35
000 at the time put it into this
thinking i was going to come back the
next season and then get more money and
then they called me up after i finished
my movie and said oh we're writing you
out of the show
so i basically bankrupted my family uh
to make this movie okay so that's not
ideal
um
but something happened because of that
you met someone
well i judd habitat was an old friend of
mine and we used to be stand-up
comedians together back in the 80s and
uh he saw the movie and really liked it
and he had just made a deal of
dreamworks because he was coming off of
the larry sanders show and said if you
have an idea for a tv show let me know
well it was in that year when i was out
promoting this movie that i never got
released on a college tour i wrote the
script for freaks and geeks and uh and
then i said it to judd and he we got it
made
[Music]